(cloche)
- À deux semaines de
la rentrée scolaire,
alors qu'une 8e vague de COVID-
19 semble poindre à l'horizon,
la ventilation dans les salles
de classe est-elle adéquate?
C'est une question que
se posent bien des parents,
comme Olivier Drouin.
OLIVIER DROUIN,
fondateur, COVID Écoles Québec
- Je m'attends que le dossier
soit réglé. J'espère,
je me croise les doigts
comme tous les parents.
- Le ministre de l'Éducation,
en visite dans une école
de Montréal, précise que
les 90 000 capteurs de CO2 sont
tous installés et fonctionnels
dans l'ensemble des salles
de classes du Québec.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE,
ministre de l'Éducation, Québec
- La rentrée qui s'en vient là,
c'est la plus belle des rentrées
en temps de COVID,
c'est-à-dire que c'est
la troisième rentrée en temps
de COVID, mais cette fois-ci,
les travaux ont été faits.
- Les enseignants seront donc
en mesure de constater en temps
réel la qualité de l'air de leur
local afin que son niveau de CO2
soit en deçà de 1000 ppm,
soit 1000 parties par millions.
- Toutes les classes devraient
atteindre cette ci
de moins de 1000 ppm.
- Quand?
- On devrait atteindre ça
dès cet automne.
- Mais pourtant, sur le site
du ministère de l'Éducation,
on précise bien que...
Or, 1500 ppm, c'est une norme
qui est loin d'être acceptable,.
Or, 1500 ppm, c'est une normeq,
selon cet expert en ventilation.
STÉPHANE BILODEAU, Département
bio-ingénierie, Uni. McGill
- Quand on accepte 1500,
c'est qu'on est très tolérant
au risque d'infection.
Si on est dans ce que beaucoup
d'experts parlent comme
une limite qui est convenable,
on est plus dans l'ordre
de 800 parties par million.
Certains mentionnent même 700.
- Le gouvernement de
la Coalition avenir Québec
estime avoir investi près
d'un demi-milliard de dollars
depuis juillet 2020 pour
améliorer la ventilation des
écoles, principal responsable
de la transmission des aérosols
vecteurs de la COVID-19.
L'installation urgente
de ventilateurs mécaniques
ou d'échangeurs d'air doit aussi
être complétée d'ici la rentrée.
Quoique eurs cas,
on privilégie encore
l'ouverture des fenêtres